let's start with joe in hartford
connecticut this hour
hey joe how are you good sir how are you
better than i deserve what's up
hey so i got a little situation um i've
been
dating this girl for a long time and uh
i could definitely see mary and her
shortly in the future
um and her brother-in-law has kind of
been involved with a lot of her finances
right now
and i've been pretty good at convincing
her not to buy a brand new car
and uh her dad is kind of out of the
picture so he kind of plays like the
alpha male role
and they're they have like a close-knit
family and he tends to take charge quite
a bit
and uh he's been definitely pushing her
to buy like a brand new hyundai palisade
or something
and uh i've been trying to convince her
to do otherwise
she's gonna have a really good job this
time next year paying really well and
i've been trying to tell her to
pay cash with something that she could
afford and
and go from there um i'm not really sure
what i should do
in my position you know being a
boyfriend and all
right what do you what do you want to do
joe i mean because you said you're the
boyfriend
um why do you want to get involved let
me ask you that question cause i think
you know the answer but why do you want
to get involved
well one because i i know she'd be in
over her head with a brand new car
and two i really really care about her
and i you know
like i said i could definitely see
burying her in the future and
you know i'm head over heels for it i
just i don't want to see her make a bad
financial mistake but
i don't want to overstep how long have
you been dating
uh quite some time about about a year
now and i've been friends with her for
years all right so it's naturally
progressing after a year towards
marriage and you don't really
uh you got two problems with this one is
uh that her
brother-in-law has too much influence
over her and two is she's about to make
a stupid decision
right yes sir yeah that's fair okay
that's fair so how can you say those two
things nice
[Laughter]
thing i i don't think you can i think
you can i think you can i mean nicer
than i just said it
but i'm not known for sugar coating
stuff so
but if you know i i think you know
you're gonna have to help here because
you're the single guy right
that's what i'm saying i don't think we
can so you're just you're just going to
jettison the girl i'm just going to tell
you baby that's a stupid move that's not
a wise decision
don't do it okay well here here i'm
going to try again
okay all right so
it might sound like this um you know
it looks like our you know we're
progressing towards making this a very
very serious relationship
and i know this is you talking okay and
i know from
reading and from some of the financial
things i've got input on
that being in agreement on
our finances is the number one
cause of divorce and marital problems
and so if we're going to continue to
progress
we're going to have to move towards
being in agreement
on our finances because not doing so
sets us up for divorce
if we wanted to get married and so we
have to
you and i have to deal with this and get
on the same page
because that's a deal breaker it's a
deal breaker before marriage or after
marriage one of the two but it's a deal
breaker it's the number one cause of
divorce
so you know you really want to deal with
the number one cause
and so you know and in light of that
you going deeply in debt on this
uh car is a is a problem
it's not wise and i want you to be in a
position to have a good life
not just have a good car and because i
care about you
and the second thing is this the number
two thing that causes problems in
marriages
is uh extended family who can't stay in
their lane
interfering mother-in-laws interfering
father-in-law's
interfering brother-in-laws that can't
stay in their lane
and so we got two of the four issues
that cause problems in marriage
in play on this one subject and so you
and i
you know i i care about you and so i've
as a part of us going forward
we've gotta i've gotta talk this through
with you in some kind of kind way
and and you gotta you're gonna have to
hear me on this because it's a
it's a big deal but now dave let me ask
you this question for joe cause joe said
he's already told her no
so it was like that's why i was saying
for me it seems like he has i'm framing
it
in we have to solve this as part of a
long-term relationship
not just you're buying a stupid thing i
got you i got you so there's a reason
that you need to listen to this because
you not listening to this is is going to
cause
serious problems in our relationship yes
because we've got interfering in-laws
with too much dominance yeah
and we've got a bad decision on finances
yeah and those two things because here's
what this projects joe for you
is uh ten years from now this is worse
not better if it doesn't truncate now
yeah that's what i'm worried about you'd
have a field day with this guy i mean
he's already in like
over a million over his head with a
brand new marina that's just the start
yeah so he he gets into debt like it's
his day job
yeah well he's not he's not going to
make it and it's going to be sad and
you're going to be sad for him because
you're
hopefully going to be married to his
sister-in-law and so you're going to get
to
witness the family going through
financial destruction when he crashes
and he will because he's a reckless
dude and so you know but the bottom line
is
if if you project negative things in a
relationship
into the marriage 10 years in yeah in
other words if you marry a princess
and you think she's not going to be a
princess 10 years in you're an idiot
she's still gonna be a princess okay if
you marry a guy girls that that
that doesn't like to work much he's lazy
you don't expect him to suddenly get
ambitious right
after there's a ring okay that that's a
dumb
yeah and so you can project these
behaviors into your future relationship
and that makes them if they're bad
enough
a deal breaker on the relationship i
mean well you've experienced this in
your dating life you've told me stories
about it absolutely but i think that's
why i'm still single because i took
the old dave ramsey philosophy i just
was like that's stupid
you know i just come straight forward
but that's i i totally agree with you
i think for me at 36 i'm like i'm done
trying to
you know be soft you know this is this
is what i think and this is what i uh
i mean you can cut to the chase pretty
quick you don't have to but you know you
don't have to go a year into it to
figure this out yes sir
like like 26 minutes into the first date
you go nope nope
ding ding 26 minutes takes me uh 10
minutes
oh whoa all right all right
i don't want to know anymore
i don't want to know your techniques you
don't need to tell them over the years i
mean those you may write a book on this
something i mean but if someone says hey
i want to do finances
or you know i want to purchase a car or
i want to stick with the credit card 10
minutes
into the game well i already know this
is this is not going where i wanted to
go
yeah and if they're belligerent about it
particularly exactly i mean if they go
well you could probably talk me out of
it okay we'll keep talking there let's
do that
if they're like and you're not gonna
change me i don't know who you think oh
goodnight
okay i won't check please